[Music]
what up guys goes on here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about all Amelio this is
different demon forms from the beginning
of the series all the way up to the
current events in the manga make sure to
smash that like button and subscribe for
more seven deadly sins and if the videos
aren't enough you can follow us on
instagram at anime uproar for daily
seven deadly sins posts and
conversations the Instagram has been
blowing up recently so definitely check
us out at anime uproar on Instagram and
help us keep the momentum going and if
you're interested in rocking seven
deadly sins inspired merch you won't
find anything better than anime uproar
calm we are selling original and epic
shirts like Eskin or praise the Sun Mele
Otisfield the wrath
demon king all hailed a king and our
newest edition featuring the son of Mele
Otis and Elizabeth our Sun of wrath
shirt you definitely won't find
something like that anywhere else so be
sure to check it out at anime our procom
the collection is constantly being
updated so you never know what will pop
up next but I can tell you that bond
shirt is in the works and it may even be
available by the time you're watching
this video let us know in the comments
if you have any shirt ideas that you'd
really love to see happen a quick
warning there will be manga spoilers in
this video so proceed with caution and
without further ado let's jump into it
Mele Otis's normal form looks completely
human he doesn't even have any demon
marks showing over the course of the
series his base power level in this form
changes from three thousand three
hundred and seventy at the beginning to
thirty two thousand five hundred after
he gets his shield power back to sixty
thousand after he gets revived after
being temporarily killed by Esther Ossa
however strong he tends to be in this
normal form he always gets stronger when
the demon mark shows itself in demon
mark mode he powers up from 3372 four
thousand four hundred and from thirty
two thousand five hundred to fifty six
thousand so demon mark mode tends to be
his first powered up mode after demon
mark mole
we have berserk mode usually when Mellie
Otis needs to break free from some form
of containment magic he undergoes a
powerful transformation to do it
however after transforming he usually
loses touch with his emotions and
becomes a killing machine
this first happened when he was sucked
into a charm called the goddess amber
the charm works on demonic beings close
to it and after reciting a chant
veronica succeeds in trapping Mellie
Otis inside even though Mellie Otis
wasn't supposed to be able to break out
of it he succeeds in doing so by
entering berserk mode in this berserk
mode he gets a huge power boost his
demon mark expands to cover a bigger
portion of his body the black markings
move to protect him from attacks making
him impervious to things that would
otherwise cut through him like swords he
can also use the darkness to form other
things like giant claws a sword or a
wing that lets him fly his powers keep
growing as the black markings expand on
his body during his fight against GLE
and he was measured to be at a power
level of 10300 in this form well above
the power level he could reach with the
demon mark mode at the time which only
put him at 4400 so it more than doubled
that power thus berserk mode did give
him a meaningful power boost but nothing
crazy he still couldn't manage to defeat
either halgrim Orgel and in this mode
next we got what is many people's
favorite form of salt mode also
translated as annihilation mode Mele
ODIs enters assault mode in order to
escape from Alaska's cocoon of Darkness
molasse qila is shocked he was able to
do it saying that none of the Ten
Commandments not even zelgius can break
out of the cocoon without using the
demon Kings power molasse Killa fears
dis mode so much that she says it's all
over for all of them she lets us know
that this is the mode that the Ten
Commandments feared when Mele oldest was
the leader of their group as Merlin
points out this mode is the result of
Mellie Otis unleashing the very limits
of his demon magic and when entering it
Mele Otis runs the risk of loose
his emotions when Mellie Otis finally
finishes entering assault mode his power
level shoots up to 140 mm in this mode
he initially loses his memories along
with his emotions and thinks he is still
the leader of the ten commandments and
doesn't seem to recognize Eskin or at
all
Mellie Otis easily overpowers Eskin or
until Eskin or enters the one mode then
Mellie Otis's opie assault mode is
defeated by the swipe of the ones hand
it is important to note that Eskin or
actually suffered more damage than
Mellie Otis during the fight but it's
still ironic how almost every time
Mellie Otis enters a new Opie form he
seems to get defeated shortly afterwards
in berserk mode he loses to Hal Burman
ghaleon and in assault mode he loses to
askin or Mellie Otis stays in this
assault mode for a while seemingly
getting stronger although he gets back
his memories his emotions don't fully
return until later perhaps the most
impressive thing we see in this mode is
how easily he takes out Esther osa
zelgius with the demon Kings power and
cusack at the same time all the while
protecting Elizabeth it is clear that in
this mode he is insanely more powerful
than he was when Esther OSA managed to
temporarily kill him
demon king possessed Mellie Otis is
another powerful and interesting form
that we get to see interestingly enough
when the demon king takes Mellie Otis's
body for himself
Mellie Otis's body ages his body starts
to look closer to bonds age than to his
usual younger looking self in this mode
Mellie Otis's older body gets a new
outfit that seems to be associated with
the power of the demon king it consists
of a white outfit with gold gloves and
boots wings of darkness and gold
tentacle like things that can change in
form and quickly attack the enemy in
this form the demon king could beat
anyone present even bond if it wasn't
for Mellie Otis's emotions raging war
against him on the inside of his body at
this point in his normal form Mellie
Otis can overpower the demon king inside
his own body however when it comes time
to break the curses that were placed on
him and Elizabeth melio dissenters a
brand new mode I would call it demon
king mode because the form looks
remarkably similar to the one that the
King used when he was in Mele Otis's
body except Mele Otis stays his usual
younger self I believe that this is how
the inner demon Lord aka demon king
power that previously awakened in Mele
Otis can manifest itself it was said
that an equal or greater power to the
demon king and supreme deity is required
to break the curses so the fact that
Mele Otis enters this mode in order to
break the curses suggests that this is
him at his strongest in this form Mele
Otis can summon more power than he's
ever been able to summon before and of
course he succeeds in breaking the
curses but at the same time this newly
awakened power is perhaps even too
strong because it was suggested that he
will no longer be able to stay in the
mortal plane for more than a day now
that he has awakened this power what do
you think
well Mele Otis had to leave the mortal
plane or will he find a way to stay
there with Elisabeth and all of the sins
let me know what your favorite mode is
in the comments you can pick anything
from his normal form all the way to his
newest demon king mode form I personally
got to go with assault mode and add
melee Otis is huge commandant soared
into the mix and you have an epically
cool design to be sure also let me know
if you were a fan of the newest form in
the comments we definitely got a lot of
mixed opinions about it on our Instagram
but in my view I like it
consistency wise it goes along with the
story and it looks cool in its own way I
like how his strongest form ended up
being a form where he didn't have to
lose control to his demonic power but
could remain in control and retain his
emotion it seems clear with the final
and strongest form that Mele Otis has
overcome the sin of Wrath and will no
longer allow himself to be consumed by
the darkness I appreciate how his Dragon
sin tattoo has evolved with him to let
me know if you think that there's any
other hidden meaning behind Mele Otis's
new and evolved dragon sin tattooed
design and that is it for today's video
all of melioidosis forms which to
quickly summarize are his normal form
his demon mark form his berserk form his
assault mode form his father possessed
me older form and finally his latest
demon
King mode form we've definitely seen a
bunch of cool transformations in this
show and I'm sad about the fact that we
probably won't be seeing any more
definitely drop a like if you enjoyed
the video if you haven't be sure to
subscribe for more seven deadly sins
videos be sure to follow us on instagram
at anime uproar where I'm putting a lot
of work to provide daily 7th at least
sense content for you guys so definitely
check us out there a big big thank you
goes out to our amazing patrons
especially to our pro tier patrons key
lot and the one and only Gilgamesh and
towards the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans Mayan golden
maddie mac 239 and a 17 FF DP thanks so
much for your ongoing support if you get
value from the stuff we do consider
supporting us for as little as $1 a
month over on our patreon if you become
a patron your name will be featured in
future videos along with these amazing
people right here and you'll get access
to our patron only discord and if you're
interested in rockin seven deadly sins
inspired merch you won't find anything
better than anime our procom we are
selling original and epic shirts like
Eskin or praise the Sun Mele Otisfield
arap demon king all hail the king and
our newest addition featuring the son of
Mele Otis and Elizabeth our son of wrath
shirt you definitely won't find
something like this anywhere else so be
sure to check it out at anime up or calm
as I said before we are always updating
the collection and I'm excited about the
new Bond shirt that is in the works and
like I said it may be available by the
time you're viewing this video I can't
wait for the bond shirts to be available
so I can snatch some for myself hashtag
all the hype thanks again and until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]